Ich muss das gleich mal geben. Gleich, gleich, gleich.
Aber außerdem noch das Bindestück zum letzten Sendung, wo wir noch mal zu dem kommen, was Johnny vorhin gesagt hat, nämlich wie und was es für Formate gibt, die noch dieses Nerds kommunizieren mit der Öffentlichkeit rausgekommen ist. So, wie war das denn jetzt damals gewesen eigentlich wirklich? Es war so gewesen, Tim.
Johnny ist schon voller Angst.
Also, nö.
Geht dein Mikrofon noch? Ja, geht noch. Also, erstmal, Johnny, wir kannten uns vorher nicht, wirklich. Also, ich glaube sogar gar nicht. Und angestoßen hat das ganze Ding Frank ursprünglich. Ich kam irgendwie aus dem Urlaub zurück und Frank sagte mir nur so, ach, übrigens, du bist jetzt auch im Radio. So, okay, alles klar. Und dann fing das irgendwie an.
Ja. Ich hab das völlig anders in Erinnerung. Entschuldige bitte, Frank.
Na ja, ist ja auch alles nicht so wild.
Nein, ehre weben und so.
Ja, also, ihr habt das irgendwie ausgekummelt und so. Wir hatten ja dieses komische Projekt da vorher. Da müssen wir jetzt nicht so drauf eingehen. Wie auch immer, auf jeden Fall.
Ein Projekt.
Ja, das machen wir noch in Berlin so, oder? Man hat ein Projekt.
Es gab da so ein Projekt. Ja, wir hatten ja irgendwie mal mit Fritz so ein komisches Labyrinth-Ding. Erinnert sich da noch?
Stimmt, er hat jetzt dieses Telefonlabel-Renn.
Eine sehr schöne Sendung, wo wir da drüber gesprochen haben, diese Frau anrief und mit dir reden wollte.
Das ist noch mal ein anderes.
Ach so, noch ein anderes Labyrinth.
Entschuldige, dass ich dir jetzt gerade zwei alte Männer vom Krieg wehre.
Aber ich muss dann wirklich mich ganz doll, ich muss dann wirklich um Entschuldigung bitten, weil dann entfrangt eigentlich derjenige, der es irgendwie zieht.
Das ist auch am Ende vollkommen egal. Wir sind da halt einfach aufgelaufen und haben irgendwie Radio, uns irgendwie diesem Radio gestellt und...
Aber warum?
Warum was?
Na, warum geht man hin und sagt so, wir sind der Chaos Competition, wir wollen jetzt Radio machen? Warum will man das?
Na ja, weil wir es konnten, weil die Gelegenheit da war, dann macht man das halt einfach mal. Es ist nicht so, dass wir uns da jetzt besonders viel Gedanken drum gemacht hätten.
Die ganze Zeit nicht?
Nee, also es war ja immer alles schon sehr spontan. Er hatte ja schon darüber gesprochen, Themenfindung und so. Kommt manchmal etwas kurzfristig. Das war Teil des Prozesses, das wirklich bis zum letzten Moment auszuschwitzen und wirklich so ein Gefühl zu haben. Okay, was ist denn jetzt eigentlich das richtige Ding? Das gehörte schon so ein bisschen dazu, weil wir mussten es ja auch wollen. Wir mussten es ja auch richtig in dem Moment als das richtige empfinden. Wir konnten nicht planen, wir planen nicht, wir machen nicht irgendwie so, ja, jetzt machen wir das, und nächsten Monat machen wir das. Und dann hast du da so einen Generalplan, den du befolgst. Sondern man fühlt einfach, was wäre denn jetzt eigentlich das, was wir a.) erzählen wollen und b.) auch erzählen können. Und dann haben wir es halt einfach gemacht. Für wen? Na sicherlich ein Stück weit auch für uns. Und zwar so diese Öffentlichkeit in dem Sinne gar nicht so klar und bewusst am Anfang. Das haben wir glaube ich erst später realisiert, dass da wirklich am anderen Ende auch Leute waren. Aber dieses Mitteilungsbedürfnis ist ja jetzt im Club nichts Neues. Also im Club hat man ja schon immer die Öffentlichkeit gesucht. Also der ganze Club ist ja sozusagen 1984 mit so einem Öffentlichkeitsstand auch erst so richtig in die Eisen gegangen durch diesen BTX-Hack. Und seitdem ist das sozusagen so eine Profession, die man sich erwirbt, wenn man im Club ist, mit der Öffentlichkeit zu sprechen. Man kennt das ja auch, wie die Sprecher sich geben und so weiter. Da sind ja mal alle ziemlich überrascht, wie viel Redefertigkeit und Formulierungspräzision da am Start ist, weil der Club das einen auch irgendwie in sich reinschleift. Man lernt das einfach zwangsläufig, wenn man dabei ist.
Na, aber da habe ich natürlich den Eindruck, dass das sehr wohlgewollt ist, wenn man, also wenn es halt so eine krasse Aktion gibt, wenn man irgendwas abfeiern kann, wenn man sich mal so richtig produzieren kann.
Könntest du das nochmal sagen?
Also was hat man gefunden?
Man hat gefunden die Zugangsdaten des BND, das hatten wir schon. Der Bundesgrenzschutzdirektion Koblenz und zumindest die Kundennummer der Deutschen Bundesbank.
Ja, es ist wirklich unglaublich, was sich alles finden lässt beim...
Das war auch so einer der Sternen, die mir angetragen wurde. Es gab uns einen großen Teelecom-Hack und da sind Dinge rausgekommen. Und Holger hat anscheinend sehr viel Spaß mit der Jingle-Maschine. Aber, und das ist halt der Punkt, das ist halt so ein Moment, da hat man was zum zeigen, da kann man halt vorgehen und sagen, ja, hier, guck mal, der Teehack, wir können, also wir haben nicht nur fachlich was total Großartiges, wir können uns auch noch sehr gekonnt darüber lustig machen. Das ist richtig gut. Und dann ist aber andererseits zu sagen, diese Dursttrecke. Und deswegen frage ich mich, warum diese Regelmäßigkeit, warum diese drei Stunden, warum in einem echten Radiosender?
Na, das war einfach das Angebot, was auf dem Tisch lag. Wir machen jetzt in diesen Blumen die Sendung, da haben wir das halt einfach gefüllt, da haben wir uns jetzt nicht weiter darüber Gedanken gemacht. Ich meine, was sollten wir überhaupt machen? Weglaufen? Wir haben halt einfach irgendwie probiert, das zu machen. Und man muss auch sagen, Johnny war am Anfang ein echter Segen, weil er uns sozusagen da abgeschirmt hat, weil wir uns überhaupt gar nicht bewusst waren, wo wir da eigentlich sind und was wir da einfach machen. Wir sind einfach reinmarschiert und haben irgendwie einfach genauso weitergequatscht, wie wir das sonst halt auch machen. Und er hat es dann irgendwie in so einen Sendungsrahmen gegossen. Das war super. Und Heugi war auch sehr hilfreich, weil du halt verstanden hast, dass es wirklich das Beste ist, uns im Wesentlichen einfach laufen zu lassen. Und daraus hat sich dann eine ganz gute Dynamik entwickelt, die so Sendungen wie die von dir schon angesprochene Wikipedia-Sendung überhaupt erst möglich gemacht hat. Weil wenn ihr mal eine Chaosradio-Sendung nachhören wollt, die ihr noch nicht kennt aus den alten Zeiten, empfehle ich immer wieder diese Wikipediasendung. Weil da war alles drin, finde ich, was Chaosradio ausgemacht hat. Dieses Live am Gerät mit so einer Chat-Community, die die Wikipedia-Community live zugehört hat und die ganze Zeit Angst hatte, dass wir jetzt gleich durch diese Sendung ihr System sprengen.
Zu Recht.
Zu Recht, genau. Aber auch mit Begeisterung dabei war. Also da war irgendwie alles drin, was in dem Moment Radio und Chaosradio auch zu leisten in der Lage war.
Aber die Antwort von Tim auf deine Frage, warum habt ihr das gemacht? Der Kernsatz ist doch, weil wir es konnten.
Ich bin tatsächlich überrascht.
Man darf auch nicht vergessen, das war damals die einzige Öffentlichkeit. Klar, du konntest jetzt noch irgendwo, weiß ich nicht, im Usenet irgendwas hinschreiben oder sonst wie. Aber es gab halt sonst keine andere Öffentlichkeit. Du hattest den Hörfunk, du hattest die Zeitung, du hattest das Fernsehen. Was anderes gab es damals noch nicht. Social Media war kein Thema, es gab noch keine Blogs.
Ich glaube aber, das hätte ich zu sagen, dass dieses Ding, das gab es auch noch anders, wo gar nicht so sehr zu unterschätzen ist.
Eigentlich muss man sagen, ab diesem Zeitpunkt war Podcast geboren, auch wenn es kein RSS-Vide hatte. So hat man regelmäßig dann auf FDP-Servern geguckt, ob irgendwie neue Folgen da sind. Und eigentlich ist ja irgendwie aus diesem Urschleim dann auch sehr viel Podcast entstanden.
Und das habe ich sozusagen im Feedback häufiger mal gehört. Also es gab früher nicht irgendwie, du hast eine App und dann kannst du einfach was abonnieren, da laufen da Audios rein, sondern diese Sendung wurde auch, also gerüchtsweise hat man erzählt, irgendwo stand ein Digitalradio, da fiel ein MP2-Stream raus und der wurde automatisiert irgendwohin geladen. Da konnte man das dann per FDP runterladen. Und das war natürlich auch so ein Ding, was da gab.
Also ich kann ihm nur voll zustimmen. Ich finde, dass wir eigentlich von Anfang an Podcasts gemacht haben, weil wir einfach normal gesprochen haben, weil wir uns nicht groß verstellt haben, weil es uns einfach um den Inhalt ging und uns eigentlich das Drumherum ziemlich egal war, mal ehrlich zu sein. Wir wollten halt einfach so unsere Themen unterbringen und wir waren unverstellt. Da war kein Unterschied zwischen vorher und während der Sendung und nach der Sendung.
Das beißt dich jetzt schon ein bisschen mit dem, was du gerade gesagt hast, dass sowohl Johnny als auch Holger euch dabei geholfen haben, die Dinge so zu tun, dass sie halt auch in dieses Format passen.
Die Freiheit gelassen haben, das so eben auch wirklich ausleben zu können und nicht groß irgendein Eimer drüber zu stülpen mit, das müsst ihr jetzt aber so machen oder so machen, sondern wir haben es halt einfach so gemacht, wie wir es in dem Moment gefühlt haben. Und ich glaube, das war auch richtig. Ich bin ja dann irgendwann, 2005 habe ich dann irgendwie diese ganze Podcasterei, als das dann so einen Namen hatte und die Infrastruktur dafür entstand, habe ich im Prinzip genau das so weitergetragen und festgestellt, dass es jetzt eigentlich keinen großen Medienbruch gibt, in dem wie ich da nach außen kommunizieren muss.
Aber ist das wirklich kein Unterschied sozusagen, weil der Vorteil bei mir, den das Chaosradio immer hatte, ist, damit erwischst du auch Leute, die haben damit nichts zu tun. Weil die schalten halt das Radio ein und zack werden sie mit einer Sache konfrontiert, die ihnen einfach so über das Bein läuft. Bei Podcasts, den muss man ja immer wollen. Also du musst eben zumindest jemand empfohlen haben, der davon Ahnung hat.
Ja, das ist dieser UKW-Mythos. Am Ende erreiste auch über Podcasts auch Leute, die nicht wussten, wo sie da geraten sind. Aber wie? Na, wie du schon sagtest, weil sie es einfach empfohlen bekommen. Und das ist halt ein anderer Zufall, aber es ist auch ein Zufall. Und man rauscht da halt irgendwie rein und stellt fest so, oh, interessant, dann höre ich mir das mal weiter an.
Also ich finde aber, die Leute, die zumindest in meiner Zeit, mit denen ich dann regelmäßig zu tun hatte, da hat man schon auch ganz klar eine Lernkurve gehört. Also du vorweg.
Wie meinst du das?
Die Art und Weise, dass es manchmal dann doch nicht totaler Quatsch ist, was so die Leute vom Radio sagen.
Ja, nee, ich habe mir auch eine alte Chaosradio-Sendung angehört.
Und wenn ich mich sprechen höre, denke ich mir auch so, oh Gott, Tim, oh mein Gott. Ja gut, aber den hat man ja immer.
Den habe ich auch oft gedacht.
Ja, den hat man immer. Aber auch diese Arroganz, die du schon angesprochen hast, klar, die war ja da. Aber wir waren uns ja selbst in dem Sinne auch überhaupt nicht gewahr. Aber insofern halt auch wirklich echt.
Genau, es war halt echt und es war natürlich auch diese Mischung aus Nervosität und zwar genauso bei mir. Also ich habe da halt Leute teilweise auch im Studio vor mir gehabt, die ich tatsächlich auch vor denen ich auch so ein bisschen ehrfurcht hatte, muss man auch so sagen.
Dass ich so dachte, wow und versuchte zu ver-
genau, wow, wow, wow, wo man halt auch nicht mal eben reingrätscht, wie wenn du irgendeinen Studio Gast hattest und sagst, ja, das war sehr interessant, aber unsere anderthalb Minuten sind leider vorbei oder so. Also es war wirklich eine Mischung aus, genau, lass das doch einfach laufen, man muss dazusagen, Holgi hatte schon Blue Moon erwähnt und es gab ja dieses Talk-Format, was sowieso eine große Freiheit hatte nachts bei Fritz. Insofern war es also jetzt nicht super ungewöhnlich, dass man da lange Gesprächstakes hat, was im Radio generell eher ungewöhnlich ist, wo man sich auf so ein anderthalb bis drei Minuten Sprachformat geeinigt hatte irgendwann und dann kommt schnell wieder Musik. Es war nicht ganz ungewöhnlich, aber trotzdem hat das Chaosradio schon immer nochmal mehr Zeit gebraucht. Und das nicht zu stoppen, trotzdem aber rein zu greschen, wenn man den Eindruck hatte, okay, jetzt wiederholen wir uns zum fünften Mal, das war halt die Herausforderung. Und da habt ihr alle total dazugelernt, allein in diesen wenigen Jahren, finde ich.
Aber glaubt ihr auch, was Tim sagt, dass diese Idee von, wir betten so einen, wie sagen wir am weitesten so einen Nerd-Content ein in ein Medium, das eher General Interest ist, also für die breite Masse, mal entschuldigen den Ausdruck, gemacht ist, so dass man die Option hat, darauf zu stoßen, dass das Quatsch ist und es eigentlich nur noch Podcasts brauchen, dann erreicht man. Ich glaube, es geht nicht so sehr um die Anzahl, sondern eher die Art von Menschen, die man damit erreichen kann.
Ich will da mal kurz was zu sagen, ihr habt ja vorhin auch schon darüber gesprochen, dieses kann man das erklären und so weiter. Ich glaube gar nicht mal, dass wir unbedingt den Anspruch hatten, immer alles irgendwie perfekt zu erklären. Ich denke auch, dass es am Ende gar nicht so wichtig war, dass das, was wir jetzt gesagt haben, perfekt dargebracht war, dass man jetzt wirklich alles verstanden hat. Ich denke, die wichtigste Aufgabe von Chaosradio zumindest in den 90ern war, den Leuten überhaupt klarzumachen, dass es uns gibt und dass es diese Welt gibt und dass es diese Sicht auf diese Welt gibt. Dass da das Internet über uns hereinbricht, dass das total wichtig, überhaupt Computertechnologie natürlich, aber Internet nochmal im Besonderen, dass das wichtig ist für diese Gesellschaft, dass wir uns damit beschäftigen, dass das eine Dimension hat, dass wir jetzt Leute sind, die sich da aus welchen Gründen auch immer die ganze Zeit mit beschäftigen und das doch bitte mal alle kurz innehalten sollen und zur Kenntnis nehmen sollen, dass das jetzt da ist. Das denke ich mal, das war so die Hauptwirkung, die Chaosradio gehabt hat. Ein Abfallprodukt war davon, dass die Leute, die uns verstanden haben oder großes Interesse dafür hatten, auf uns aufmerksam geworden sind. Am Anfang war ja Chaosradio für uns vor allem eine extreme Recruiting-Veranstaltung. Da kamen nach zwei, drei Jahren einfach die Nerds aus allen Ecken angelaufen und so, weil die auf uns aufmerksam geworden sind und dieser unglaubliche Auftrieb, den der Club hatte in dieser Zeit, gerade in dieser Zeit von 95 bis 2005, da ist ja sehr viel passiert. Der Kongress ist nach Berlin gekommen, das ist alles enorm gewachsen und das hatte sehr viel mit Chaosradio zu tun.
Spricht aber eigentlich auch dafür, dass man es gerne auf einem möglichst breiten Kanal haben will. Aber ich würde gerne noch mal von Johnny und Holgi wissen, was ihr davon haltet.
Ja, ich bin eigentlich auch schon immer der Meinung gewesen, dass das auf UKW zu verbreiten gerade gut ist, weil nämlich Menschen, die gerade im Auto unterwegs sind und Radio hören und irgendwie auf dem nächstgelegenen Sender, ich weiß gar nicht, was ist denn das, Energy oder so, wenn du von Energy runter skippst, dann landest du bei Fritz und dann reden da auf einmal ein paar Leute über Dinge, von denen du schon mal gehört hast, also das sind Worte, die du schon mal gehört hast, sie werden nur in einen Kontext gesetzt, der dir völlig fremd ist. Und die Rückmeldung, die es immer mal wieder gab, auch zum Chaosradio, immer mal wieder gab, die kommt sehr selten, aber sie kommt und die lautet, ich bin im Auto sitzen geblieben und ich habe das zu Ende gehört, dabei wusste ich vorher gar nicht, dass das überhaupt existiert und das ist glaube ich ein Asset, das nur UKW, also nur Broadcast, dir wirklich bringen kann, weil du einfach diese Zufälligkeit, die du schon gesagt hast, es ist heute eine andere Aufmerksamkeit, die da kommt und du musst halt wirklich auch bereit sein, anderthalb Stunden erst mal zuzuhören, also wenn du gesagt hast, hör dir das mal an, das ist total interessant, das ist aber drei Stunden lang, wann soll ich mir das denn anhören?
Da mussten ja die Leute ja auch im Auto sitzen bleiben, damit sie das überhaupt hören können, heute gehen sie einfach nochmal mit dem Kopfhörer auf dem Block.
Ja, aber Absolut.
Aber absolut.
Aber ob sie das tun, ist noch eine andere Frage.
Die Frage, die ich mir halt auch immer wieder stelle, ist, finden wir drei das vielleicht nur deswegen geil, weil wir vom Radio kommen und nicht von woanders her?
Ja, aber Tim, wenn du jetzt so mit dem Kopf schüttelst, dann heißt das auch, dass du deine These nur deswegen geil findest, weil du Podcaster bist.
Weil du vom Internet bist.
Um nicht falsch verstanden zu werden, das war super. Also das war für uns damals sicherlich unter Garantie das richtige Medium.
Es gab ja auch nichts anderes.
Es gab auch in dem Sinne nichts Vergleichbares zumindest und hat alles einen guten Weg genommen und war total super. Ab einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt war mir dann aber auch klar, die Zukunft liegt im Netz. Und ich denke, was wir jetzt so sehen mit Podcasts, was sich daraus jetzt so entwickelt hat. Ich meine, du bist ja auch am Senden, Holger ist auch am Senden, du hast es eigentlich auch sehr lange gemacht.
Machst du eigentlich noch Podcasts, Johnny?
Warum nicht?
Ich habe tatsächlich reine Zeitprobleme.
Okay, das ist eine gute Ausrede und ansonsten hat sich ja gezeigt, dass sich das, wie gesagt, nur so schön demokratisiert hat. Also jetzt kann jeder quasi seine eigene Idee sein.
Aber du wolltest zu dem Thema noch was sagen.
Also, weiß ich nicht, ich glaube, diese Zufälligkeit, die darf man nicht unterschätzen und die sehe ich bei Podcasts so auch nicht. Also das hat natürlich damit zu tun, dass man, keine Ahnung, ich höre morgens Radio zum Beispiel und da wechsle ich auch Kanäle irgendwie, also da mache ich auch keinen Podcast an, wenn ich im Bad bin.
Du bist auch alt, Johnny.
Die Leute, die ziehen das mittlerweile aus der Timeline raus.
Alt?
Wer noch?
Egal.
Ich bin alt, ja, aber ich bin alt, ich weiß es auch.
Aber ganz kurz, ich bin alt, aber ich habe zwei jugendliche Söhne und die hören definitiv weder Radio noch Podcast morgens, sondern die hören halt ihre Playlist. Also die wollen halt Musik unter der Dusche hören.
Tim, wir müssen auf Spotify.
Ich nenne es mal Memen, die jungen Leute wollen gar keine komplexen Themen. Haltet ihr das für tragbar?
Das halte ich für ganz großen Schwarzsinn. Die Frage ist vielleicht, wer sollte den jungen Leuten die komplexen Themen vermitteln? Möglicherweise ist Radio dazu nicht mehr da. Das Angebot ist so breit geworden, wenn du heute hingehst und sagst, ich mache jetzt hier Hörfunk und vermitle komplexe Themen über UKW. Alleine der Umstand, dass du zeitunsouverän das Ganze hören musst. Das findet halt zu einem bestimmten Zeitpunkt statt. Also ist so ein Stream, in dem du dich wieder ausklinkst und zwischendrin hast du dieses komplexe Thema mitgenommen. Das ist ein Konzept aus dem letzten Jahrtausend. Das funktioniert glaube ich heute einfach nicht mehr so.
Wie dann?
Podcast.
Früher sind die Leute ja auch nicht den ganzen Tag mit Kopfhörern durchgekriegt. Das ist jetzt einfach Standard.
Aber wäre dann sozusagen die gekonnte Mischung, man macht eine Sendung, produziert die als Podcast und bietet die dann auf beiden Kanälen an, damit man einerseits die Zufälligkeit hat und andererseits das runterladen?
Ja.
Sowas wie das Chaosradio?
Die Frage ist ja, was ist das definierende Format? Und natürlich kann man seinen Podcast so auslegen, dass er möglichst wiederverwendbar ist. Chaosradio, auch viele Podcasts, die aus dieser Szene kommen, werden schon seit Jahren auf freien Radios zum Beispiel in die Slots mit reingeworfen, ohne dass es da viel größere Absprache gibt. Also diese UKW-Ausstrahlung findet auch statt und auch so. Also man muss gar nicht speziell in einem UKW dominierten Rahmen produzieren, um solche Ausspielungskanäle nutzen zu können. Das ergibt sich von alleine und da muss man sich eigentlich gar nicht groß drum kümmern.
Also du kannst halt deine komplexen Themen in eine Sendung gießen, du kannst das als Podcast machen und das Zapping, was wir alten Leute noch an diesem Radiodrehknopf haben, das übernimmt dann halt im Zweifelsfall ein Social Network, also Twitter im Zweifelsfall. Darüber kommen dann so Empfehlungskaskaden. Hör dir das mal an. Natürlich ist das in einer ganz anderen Größenordnung möglicherweise. Weil so ein UKW-Sender, zumindest wenn man diesen Zahlen, die die da produzieren, glaubt, erreicht auf einen Schlag im Zweifelsfall mal eben 100.000 Leute, die du da zumindest anfixen kannst für deine Sendung. Das hast du sicherlich auf Twitter nicht, aber vielleicht willst du das auch gar nicht. Weil letztendlich sind die 100.000 Leute, die du mit UKW erreicht hast, ein Schrot-Schuss in so einem großen Saal. Da triffst du halt ein oder zwei. Die bleiben dann hängen. Aber die ein oder zwei, die triffst du halt auch auf Twitter.
Ja, ist doch die Frage, ob die selben meint. Das ist das, was ich vor allem meinte. Zahlenmäßig vielleicht, aber ist die Frage. Aber Johnny, noch du zu jungen Menschen kompletiv.
Generell stimme ich Heugi zu. Dieses Konzept von zeitabhängigem Konsum von Audiomedien ist einfach vorbei. Also Menschen, die mit Netflix und Spotify und wie es auch alles heißt, irgendwie aufwachsen, die verstehen das gesamte Konzept von, da ist um 20.15 Uhr irgendeine Sendung im Fernsehen. Natürlich überhaupt nicht. Es gibt aber zwei Bremsen noch, die ich beim Podcast sehe. Die eine ist, wir leben in einer in Deutschland extrem alten Gesellschaft. Und diese alte Gesellschaft fährt auch noch Auto. Und Autos, Autoradios sind einfach noch ein wahnsinniges Transportmittel für Audiomedien.
Ich glaube, Autoradios retten das Radio.
Deswegen, solange wir nicht wirklich so Radio-Streams oder Podcasts auch im Auto haben, das ist einfach noch ein Hemmschuh. Und der andere große Hemmschuh für mich persönlich, weil Tim gerade gefragt hat, warum machst du keine Podcasts mehr? Es gibt noch ein paar andere Gründe, warum ich keine persönlichen Podcasts mehr mache, weil ich da teilweise so persönlich war, dass es mir dann echt ein bisschen spooky wurde, in bestimmten Lebenssituationen, wo man drauf angesprochen wurde von Menschen. Aber es ist noch eine andere Geschichte. Aber ich würde total gerne eine ein- oder zweistündige Musiksendung machen als Podcast, also wo man wirklich Musik spielt und über Musik spricht. Also über, weiß ich nicht, ich hätte total Bock, Musik aus allen Jahrzehnten zu spielen, mit verschiedensten Verbindungen, die ich herstellen kann aus einer bestimmten Zeit.
Aber es ist unmöglich.
Es geht einfach nicht. Und jetzt kann man sagen, wegen der GEMA? Ja, es gibt da den entsprechenden Tarif nicht, aber Podcasts fehlt Musik. Das ist für eine Sendung wie das Chaosradio nicht der wichtige Bestandteil, für viele andere Sendungen auch. Und wenn es wirklich, was diese Ebene angeht, wenn es irgendwas gibt, dann gebt mir einen verdammten Tarif dafür, dass ich Podcasts machen kann, in denen ich Songs spielen kann. Und von mir aus quattere ich da ein bisschen drüber, weil niemanden, der oder die diese Sendung hört, wird es darum gehen, den Song rauszuschneiden. Das ist ja vorbei, also ich meine, sorry. Wir kriegen inzwischen für einen Zehner im Monat fast alle Musik der Welt.
Ich kenne nur einen Podcast mit Musik und der macht halt nur freie Musik, das ist die Machtdose.
Immer noch.
Ich hätte an euch beide jetzt noch eine letzte Frage. Für Podcasts wünsche ich euch Musik. Beim Chaosradio ist es so, das ist ja heute das letzte auf Fritz. Das heißt aber, es kann noch ein weiteres Chaosradio geben. Was würdet ihr euch fürs Chaosradio wünschen? Oder vom Chaosradio?
Der Richter wieder mit seinen Fragen, was toll ist denn das?
Oder ist es jetzt auch gut?
Ne, das sollte schon weiter senden, das Chaosradio. Es sollte vielleicht wirklich, und auch das ist jetzt eher metaphorisch gemeint, es sollte vielleicht wirklich bei Sendung eins nochmal anfangen und mit jungen Augen, also mit neuen Augen auf die Themen gucken, die wir Alten damals schon besprochen haben, die nochmal neu bewerten. Das fände ich glaube ich eine sehr, sehr spannende Zukunft auch. Und es passiert ja auch noch genug ein neuer Krempel, der dann auch noch begutachtet werden muss.
Genau, der neue Krempel, den finde ich auch wichtig. Also ein Phänomen wie TikTok zum Beispiel, es geht an vielen Leuten völlig vorbei. Weil völlig klar ist, also das Tolle ist ja, man muss niemanden mehr erklären, dass dieses Digitale durchaus wichtig ist.
Das Internet geht nicht weg.
Was? Da, weiß ich jetzt nicht.
Hast du wirklich den Eindruck, dass man das niemandem mehr erklären muss? Ich habe sehr wohl den Eindruck, dass man das nicht mehr erklären muss.
Nein, ich habe, nein, also das muss man niemandem erklären. Aber genau, was man auch nicht vergessen darf, es gibt ganz viele Fragen, die wahnsinnig schwierig zu lösen sind oder zu beantworten sind, finde ich. Also gerade wenn dann irgendwie juristisches mit Blah zusammenkommt, Regulierungsfragen und, und, und. Und wie geht man mit großen Plattformanbietern um und so weiter und so fort. Aber auch zum Beispiel die Tatsache, dass natürlich eine Generation, dass wir zum ersten Mal jetzt eine Generation haben, die komplett digital aufgewachsen ist. Also dass es einfach jetzt Menschen gibt, die sind auf die Welt gekommen und es gab das Internet. Die kennen keine Welt ohne Internet und das ist ein irrer Switch, finde ich. Also das ist wirklich was komplett Neues und die haben aber auch wieder ein ganz anderes Internet als wir. Also das stellen wir doch alle immer wieder fest. Und da meine ich jetzt einmal die ganz jüngeren und dann haben wir aber auch noch die Herausforderungen der Alten, die zum Beispiel, die ins Internet gekommen sind, ohne Modem sowieso nicht, aber nicht mal mit einem Desktoprechner, sondern die von 0 auf 100 ins Internet springen mit einem Smartphone und WhatsApp.
Und für die soll das Chaosradio dann?
Ja, also ich finde schon die Herausforderung ist, ob die jetzt da reinhören, weiß ich nicht, aber ich glaube, dass diese ganz verschiedenen Zielgruppen durchaus auch eine Chaosradio-Zielgruppe. Sein können, weil wenn wir über Fake News reden, WhatsApp ist die große Herausforderung, wo nämlich der ganze politische Kram, ich kriege das wirklich selber mit, geteilt wird, ohne darüber nachzudenken und so, wo die wirklich in Memes rumgehen, und zwar die politischen und die auch durchaus propagandistisch zu bezeichnen sind, bla bla, dann die junge Generation, die längst in ganz anderen Kanälen unterwegs ist.
Und das ist die von Chaosradio?
Das ist das Chaosradio, dass alles also einerseits genau zurückgehen, bestimmte Basistechnologien schon nochmal beleuchten und andererseits aber auch frisch weiterguckt, was passiert eigentlich. Ich finde immer, die gesellschaftliche Ebene fast spannender als die technologische. Fast. Nein, aber mich interessiert immer, was hat das für eine Auswirkung auf unser Leben alles und dann ist es ganz wichtig, Technologie auch zu kennen und ein Stück weit zu verstehen. Aber diese Auseinandersetzung mit dem, was bedeutet das eigentlich für uns alle, was bedeutet das für die, die sich viel oder wenig mit Technologie auskennen. Diese Ebene ist immer die, die ich am spannendsten finde.
Das heißt, im Grunde müsstest du ein Chaosradio machen, das du übers Netz verbreitest für die jungen Leute und gleichzeitig bei Radio Berlin 88, Antenne Brandenburg, für die Leute, die von 0 auf 100 über ihr Tablet mit WhatsApp sofort ins Internet gekommen sind.
Mach deine 5 Minuten Zusammenfassung.
Wir hatten ja damals immer einen klaren Feind, das war irgendwie bunty clicky, heute ist es irgendwie Facebook und ich denke eine Botschaft von Chaosradio war von Anfang an immer, ein anderes Netz ist möglich und das muss man halt einfach immer wieder betonen.
Das musst du den Facebookern aber auch sagen.
Machen wir ja auch.
Ja, aber dann musst du aber auch immer wieder betonen, ein anderes Netz ist möglich mit fast zwei Milliarden Facebook-Nutzern, also du musst halt auch den Realitäten ins Auge gucken.
Eine Diskussion, die wir an einer anderen…
Jetzt wird es aber erst spannend.
Ach, Realität.
Eine Diskussion, die wir an einer Stelle vielleicht mal weiterführen können. Es gibt auch dazu eine Idee, vielleicht trifft also ihr beiden euch demnächst mal wieder. Ich möchte mich an dieser Stelle von Holger Klein und Johnny Haeusler verabschieden. Vielen Dank, dass ihr da wart und nochmal mit zurückgegangen seid. Sehr gerne. Johnny und Holger, vielen Dank. Dankeschön. Wir machen gleich nochmal eine halbe Stunde mit, naja, ich stelle es mal auf den Erben des Chaosradios vor, aber noch eine kleine Musik und dann nochmal Nachrichten mit Wetter und Verkehr.
Wo ist das denn?
Direkt vor deiner Tür.
Und wie komme ich da hin?
Nee, Quatsch.
Interrail. Bahn frei für eure Reise kreuz und quer durch unseren Kontinent.
Einfach gewinnen.
Und ab kommenden Montag im Radio.
Um 23.34 Uhr mit Merlin Schulz. Italien sollte die knapp 50 Flüchtlinge an Bord der Sea-Watch 3 an Land gehen lassen. Das haben mehrere UN-Organisationen in einer gemeinsamen Erklärung gefordert. Darin heißt es, wegen der kritischen Situation auf dem Schiff sei es dringend notwendig, dass die Menschen unverzüglich von Bord gehen dürfen. Die Sea-Watch 3 hatte die Migranten am 19. Januar vor Libyen aufgenommen. Italiens Innenminister Salvini erklärte, er werde seine Meinung nicht ändern. Die Regierung in Rom verbietet privaten Rettungsschiffen seit Monaten in den Häfen des Landes anzulegen. Die Bundesregierung hat sich auf einen Entwurf zur Neuregelung des Paragrafen 219a geeinigt. Danach sollen künftig auch Ärzte und Kliniken zum Beispiel auf ihren Internetseiten darüber informieren dürfen, dass sie Abtreibungen durchführen. Betroffene Frauen kämen so an alle nötigen Angaben, sagte Justizministerin Barley. Ursprünglich war geplant, dass nur staatliche Stellen bekannt geben dürfen, welche Ärzte und Krankenhäuser Abbrüche vornehmen. Das ist nun zusätzlich geplant. Bundespräsident Steinmeier hat zum Auftakt seines Staatsbesuchs in Inthitopien eine engere Zusammenarbeit zwischen Europa und Afrika gefordert. Auf globale Herausforderungen wie Klimawandel und Migration könne man nur gemeinsam Antworten finden, sagte Steinmeier. Äthiopien gehört zu den ärmsten Ländern der Welt. Unter Regierungschef Ahmed wurden seit April zahlreiche Reformen eingeleitet. Dazu gehören einen Friedensvertrag mit dem Nachbarland Eritrea und eine Amnestie für politische Gefangene. Auf Kuba sind bei einem Tornado mindestens drei Menschen ums Leben gekommen und mehr als 170 verletzt worden. Vor allem in der Hauptstadt Havanna habe der Sturm schwere Schäden angerichtet, schrieb Kubas Präsident Dias Kanell auf Twitter. Das genaue Ausmaß der Schäden ist noch nicht bekannt. Der US in das CNN berichtete, der Tornado habe auch in der Umgebung Havannas Überschwemmungen ausgelöst. Aktuell liegen die Temperaturen in Berlin und Brandenburg zwischen 0 und plus 2 Grad. Bis zum Morgen sind immer wieder Regen, Schneeregen und Schneemöglich und es kann glatt werden bei Tiefswerten um minus 3 Grad. Der Tag startet mit Schnee, der lässt dann nach und macht Platz für einen Mix aus Sonne und Wolken. Später sind dann wieder Schnee und Schneeregen schaumöglich, das Ganze bei Höchstwerten von 2 bis 4 Grad. Mit zwei Meldungen zum Stadtverkehr Berlin, Vorsicht in Marzahn auf dem Blumberger Damm, da sind in Höhe Landsberger Allee die Ampeln außer Betrieb, Fahrter bitte entsprechend vorsichtig. Und in Mitte ist die Stresemannstraße zwischen Niederkirchner und Erner Bergerstraße bis zum Morgen wegen eines Kraneinsatzes gesperrt. Allen unterwegs und da, wo es geht, eine gute Fahrt.
Mehr aktuelle Infos rbb24.de Und wenn ihr Fritz im Live- oder Musikstream hören wollt, dann geht doch mal auf fritz.de slash Streambox.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio 253, live aus dem Seelchen Berlin. Könnten wir noch mal einen Applaus für die letzte halbe Stunde haben? Und wir haben die Besetzung hier beim letzten Chaosradio auf Fritz fast komplett ausgetauscht. Herzlich willkommen Katrin Rönicke.
Hallo.
Jochen Dreier.
Ulf Buermeyer.
Hallo.
Und nochmal Tim Pritlove.
Und warum sitzen jetzt so viele Leute mit anderen Gesichter hier als gerade noch auf dem Sofa saßen? Dahinter gibt es eine Idee. Und die Idee ist, dass wir versucht haben, die These aufzustellen, dass Chaosradio so eine Schnittstelle zwischen Nerds und allgemeiner Öffentlichkeit. Das heißt, Menschen, die von einem Thema sehr viel verstehen, wollen das mit Dendungsbewusstsein irgendwo hintragen. Und das ist einerseits das Silizium-Nerds, also Technik, Kram, aber man kann das auch in anderen Fachbereichen machen. Und all die Menschen, die jetzt hier sitzen, die euch auf Chaosradio, die ihr auch im Video angucken könnt, sind Vertreter dieser Spezies. Und Tim hat ja schon den Lobgesang des Podcasts angestimmt. Es sind alles Vertreter eines Podcasts, mit einer Ausnahme, dass auch im Radio passiert. Und die Idee ist jetzt vor allen Dingen, liebe Fritz-Hörerinnen und Hörer, weil das Chaosradio ja demnächst nicht mehr in dieser Form zumindest auf eurer Antenne geben wird oder auf eurer Podcastseite fritz.de, dass ihr vielleicht noch mal ein paar Ansatzpunkte habt. Wo kann man denn noch so Dinge hören, die einen ähnlichen Ansatz haben? Und das sind Logbuch, Netzpolitik, Die Lage der Nation, Breitband und der lila Podcast. Und ich würde jetzt gerne der Reihe nach bei euch abfragen, was ist denn es eigentlich? Warum macht ihr das und für wen sendet ihr? Ich werde trotzdem dieses Wort benutzen. Tim, fang noch mal an mit gutem Beispiel. Logbuch, Netzpolitik. Ist das so was wie ein Chaosradio, ein Podcast?
Gute Frage. Ich habe ja 2005 angefangen, ein Chaosradio auszukoppeln, was dann Chaosradio Express hieß. Das war so der vergebliche Versuch, dem Chaosradio sozusagen so ein Kurzformat hinzuzufügen.
Warte, ist das nicht der Podcast, der so mindestens dreieinhalb Stunden geht, eher länger?
Ja, das Konzept ist total gescheitert, aber es ist in etwas ganz Nettes anderes übergegangen. Er hat zumindest gezeigt, diese Idee, komplexe Themen zu behandeln im Gespräch, dass das auch weiterhin funktionieren kann. Und das war eigentlich schon immer meine Überzeugung, dass man das noch sehr weit treiben kann und beileibe nicht nur eben auf diese Internetthemen machen kann. Lokbo-Netzpolitik ist jetzt später entstanden, einfach so aus der Betrachtung heraus, okay, Netzpolitik an sich ist einfach ein wichtiges Thema, weil es eben eine wichtige politische Komponente ist, so wie das ganze Netz. Wichtig ist eben dann auch der konkrete politische Ausgestaltungsrahmen wichtig. Und ja, ich habe mich dann vor einigen Jahren mit Linus Neumann zusammengetan, der da sehr bewandt und berät ist und habe mich eigentlich selber auch sehr viel mehr in die Rolle eines Co-Moderators und Produzenten begeben und wir haben dann halt gemeinsam angefangen, diese Themen auf unsere Art zu diskutieren und so zugänglich zu machen.
Wie oft dennet ihr?
Einmal die Woche, wenn es hinaut.
Und für wen?
Für jeden, die es interessiert.
Aber habt ihr denn Feedback sozusagen, dass ihr uns eher Leute hören, die...
Ich glaube, dass uns mittlerweile alle möglichen Leute... Ich könnte das überhaupt gar nicht groß charakterisieren. Also Leute... Ich denke, es hat auch ein bisschen was damit zu tun, wie wir das rüberbringen, dass Leute sich... Anders gesagt, grundsätzlich finde ich es wichtig, dass man, wenn man was zu erzählen hat, sich auch halbwegs bemüht, es auch unterhaltsam zu machen, zugänglich zu machen, den Humor nicht zu verlieren, natürlich zu sein, persönlich zu sein und klar zu machen, von welcher Position aus man diskutiert. Gar nicht so eine große Hierarchie da entstehen zu lassen, Unterschiede entstehen zu lassen, sondern einfach nur zu sagen, hey, wir sind ja einfach auch nur so ein paar hergelaufene Nerds, wir beschäftigen uns einfach nur ein bisschen mehr damit und hier, das ist das, was wir da sehen. Mal gucken, wie ihr das so findet.
Das sind aktuelle Aufhänger jeweils in der Woche.
In dem Fall ist es halt sehr newsgetrieben.
Die Lage der Nationen, wer ist das? Was macht ihr da und für wen?
Ja, die Lage der Nationen behandelt genau das. Die politische Lage der Nationen, und das verstehen wir aber natürlich so ein bisschen augenzwinkern, das ist die politische Lage in Deutschland und der Welt. Die Lage der Nationen hofft, ein gutes Gespräch zu sein, und zwar zwischen Philipp Banzel, der ist vor allem Politikjournalist, Radiojournalist, vor allem beim Deutschlandfunk, aber auch schon ein Urgestein der deutschen Podcastszene. Und der zweite Mann an Bord bin ich, Ulf Buermeyer. Genau, wir haben etwa jede Woche eine Sendung. Meistens wird Freitag oder Samstag aufgenommen. Es geht so etwa 90 Minuten über circa fünf, sechs Themen, was gerade politisch los war in der Woche. Und wir denken, dass das eigentlich ein Programm ist, das jeden interessieren sollte. Wir haben im Sommer vergangenen Jahres mal eine Umfrage gemacht, und danach kann man das auch ablesen, dass das doch ein relativ breites Publikum ist. Also ich sag mal, so über 60 bricht es etwas ab, aber bis dahin sind doch sehr, sehr viele Leute dabei. Fräulicherweise auch fast gleich verteilt Männer und Frauen und Menschen mit sehr unterschiedlichen beruflichen und Bildungshintergrund. Also die Idee der Lage ist tatsächlich, Politik und das, was drum herum passiert, ist so zu erklären, dass es für jedermann, für jede Frau verständlich ist.
Man kann beim Blog und Internet-Politik sagen, das sind auch die Leute aus dem Club, also im weitesten Sinne, weil sowohl Linus als auch Tim sind ja CCC-Leute. Wer seid ihr?
Wie gesagt, Philipp ist zum einen Podcaster seit über zehn Jahren und hat zum anderen Journalismus studiert, viele, viele Jahre schon für den Deutschlandfunk gearbeitet. Das macht er auch heute weiter und fürs Deutschlandradio Kultur. Seit über 13 Jahren ist der Podcast. Ich glaube, seit 2004, 2005. Also Philipp, deswegen sagte ich, ist Urgestein seit ewigen Zeiten dabei. Und Philipp und ich sind auch schon länger befreundet und haben uns interessanterweise auch über ein anderes Podcastformat kennengelernt. Er betreibt nämlich schon seit ewigen Zeiten das Küchenradio. Und da war ich mal als Podcast Gast dabei bei einer Folge, die auf einem Chaos Communication Congress aufgenommen wurde. Genau, also es ist in der Tat so, dass der Gründungsmythos unserer Freundschaft, wenn man so will, auch sehr viel mit dem Club zu tun hat. Genau, und ich selber bin von Haus aus Jurist, habe lange als Richter gearbeitet hier in Berlin, bin im Moment am Berliner Verfassungsgerichtshof tätig, als wissenschaftlicher Mitarbeiter und ansonsten so als Haupthobby, Vorsitzender der Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte. Das ist so eine Bürgerrechtsorganisation, die vor allem mit Klagen für Grundrechte kämpft.
Da gibt es auch, glaube ich, ein Chaosradio dazu.
Da gibt es auch mehrere Chaosradio-Folgen. Wir machen das, weil wir versuchen wollen, ein gutes Gespräch über Politik zu führen. Wir hatten so ein bisschen den Eindruck, dass insbesondere im Fernsehen doch so diese 15-Sekunden-Schnipsel häufig dominieren oder allenfalls 30 Sekunden. Und wir wollen uns einfach ein bisschen mehr Zeit nehmen, um über Politik zu sprechen. Wir versuchen, Hintergründe zu erklären. Also der Podcast hat schon einen sehr großen, glaube ich, Erklär-Bear-Faktor, wenn wir ja selbst ironisch immer mal wieder sagen. Das gilt besonders für juristische Themen, weil das einfach quasi so mein Heimatthema ist. Ich komme ja eben aus der Juristerei. Aber wir versuchen auch, viele Nerd-Themen einzubauen. Also natürlich nicht so umfangreich wie Logbuch-Netzpolitik, aber es kommen auch jedenfalls dann Nerd-Themen, Technik-Themen vor, denke ich, wenn sie so die Politik allgemein beeinflussen. Also denken wir an diesen Daten-Leak jetzt vor einigen Wochen. Diese Doxing-Attacke, da haben wir natürlich auch versucht, den Hörerinnen und Hörern zu erklären, was da eigentlich schiefgegangen war.
Also ich muss jetzt sagen, jetzt wird es ein bisschen komisch. Ich bin selbst auch bei Breitband Moderator, aber ich muss jetzt als Chaosradio-Moderator fragen, Jochen, was ist denn Breitband?
Ja, was ist Breitband, Marcus? Ich bin ja jetzt ja noch Vertreter für eine ganze Redaktion, wenn man so will. Ich würde sagen, wir sind so 10 bis 15 Leute, die beim Deutschland von Kultur immer samstags eine Sendung machen. Jetzt laut genug. Das Radio ist ganz neu für mich. Und das geht jetzt ins 11. Jahr, 2019 ist das 11. Jahr Breitband, das ist auch schon relativ lange dabei. Und interessanterweise werden wir auch immer ein bisschen als Podcast wahrgenommen, weil wir auch sehr früh und sehr lange schon immer Netzmusik nehmen, Creative Commons Musik, die immer die ganze Sendung schon als Podcast hochgeladen haben und es halt auch wirklich halt danach nachhörbar war. Und das war halt neu und anders. Und ja, die Themen sind halt, ich würde sagen, Medien und Netzkultur, aber auch so, dass wir einfach versuchen, an die Themen so ranzugehen, dass wir von der Soziologie drauf gucken, ein bisschen philosophischer das Ganze denken. Also das Technische so ein bisschen gesellschaftlich zu übersetzen. Also es ist jetzt keine nerdige Technik-Sendung. Ich glaube, da hat die Deutsche Funk mit Computer und Kommunikation so ein bisschen mehr eine Technik-Sendung. Und wir sind halt eher, finde ich, so ein bisschen wie das Deutschland-Funk-Kultur halt auch ist, so ein bisschen Vögeltau, wenn ich so weiß.
Vögeltau fürs Internet?
Ja, ja, vielleicht so ein bisschen schon. Ich finde das aber eigentlich auch einen richtigen Ansatz, dass man halt immer sagt, lass uns da doch mal mit einer Philosophin drüber sprechen. Lass uns da doch mal jetzt nicht nur das Technische erklären, weil das ist tatsächlich nicht das, was es am Ende ausmacht für die Menschen, sondern lass uns wirklich tiefer darüber nachdenken, wie verändert das die Gesellschaft und da das irgendwie so zu verbinden. Die Gedanken über uns sollen in der Redaktionssitzung entstehen, weil gerade irgendwas wieder passiert ist und wir sagen, was ist das eigentlich? Jetzt haben wir gerade Vertrauen gehabt. Aber was heißt eigentlich Vertrauen, wenn wir Facebook nicht mehr vertrauen? Was heißt Vertrauen, wenn es Monopole sind? Ist Vertrauen dann wirklich wichtig? Das finde ich interessante Fragen und da kann man mit sehr vielen spannenden Menschen darüber sprechen und hoffe, das kommt auch an.
Und das sind aber sozusagen, das ist eine richtige Radiosendung, da gibt es mehrere Themen in sehr kurzer Zeit, wenn man aus dem BestBitGib der Podcasts daraus guckt.
Klassisch ist es eine Magazinsendung mit Interviews, Beitrag, Bildung, aber wir haben halt auch ein Talkformat, wo dann eine Stunde wirklich darüber.
Mit Philipp Banzer.
Die Welt ist nicht so groß.
Die Welt ist überhaupt nicht groß, nee.
Die Lila Podcast.
Ja, wenn Nerds die Fachidioten sind, die manchmal so ein bisschen abseits der Gesellschaft stehen, dann sind wir wahrscheinlich die Fachidioten für Feminismus, würde ich sagen. Und wir kommen so aus der Richtung, dass wir auch versuchen, eben das aus dem Abseits der Gesellschaft in die Gesellschaft reinzuholen. Das war ja vorhin ganz viel Thema. Wie schafft man das mit diesen ganzen Technik und digitalen Themen? Und wir versuchen das eben mit Feminismus zu machen. Haben das zuerst versucht über ein Blog, das heißt Mädchenmannschaft. Also meine zwei Kolleginnen Susanne Klingner und Barbara Streidel haben das 2007, glaube ich, gegründet und da geblockt und geblockt. Ich bin 2008 dazu gekommen, ist also auch schon alles wieder über zehn Jahre her. Und dann kam Trim Pritlove und hat mich eingeladen in sein Chaosradio Express, das dann aber tatsächlich schon irgendwie drei Stunden zwanzig ging. Und wir haben über Feminismus geredet und ich habe festgestellt, ach guck mal, wenn man über Feminismus redet und nicht darüber schreibt, dann kommt ja viel mehr bei den Leuten an. Dann kommen viel mehr Zwischentöne an und die Diskussionen werden auf einmal konstruktiver. Und so sind wir dann zu diesem Podcast gekommen, dass ich dann gesagt habe, okay, ich will jetzt eigentlich nur noch so mit Leuten kommunizieren und nicht mehr dieses. Also wir hatten in diesem alten Blog mehrere Tausend dieser typischen Hasskommentare, wie man sie ja auch von Heise, Forum und ich weiß nicht, was kennt. Die haben wir da auch schön gesammelt, natürlich nicht veröffentlicht, aber wir haben sie immer mal wieder gesehen. Und das kennen wir jetzt in diesem Podcast gar nicht mehr. Also von daher, genau.
Wie oft sendet ihr?
Wir senden mittlerweile auch wöchentlich. Also wir haben angefangen mit monatlich, dann wurde es zwei wöchentlich. Und inzwischen sind wir wöchentlich, weil wir festgestellt haben, wir haben immer noch so viele Themen. Es gibt immer noch so viele Sachen, die wir machen wollen. Wir kommen überhaupt nicht hinterher. Wir haben so einen Workflow zusammen, wo wir immer Themen reinschmeißen und festgestellt haben, so ja, damit können wir jetzt das nächste halbe Jahr füllen. Wie sollen wir das machen?
Meine Podcasts sind immer zu monatlich.
Keine Zielgruppe. Also das ist genau das, was Tim auch gesagt hat, dass es uns eigentlich wichtig ist, möglichst breit anzukommen. Jetzt haben wir dieses komische Spotify, was vorhin auch schon anklang. Da sieht man so ein bisschen die Leute, die einen hören. Und die liegen so zwischen 18 und 35, die meisten. Also auch Spotify, was natürlich wieder eine eingeschränkte Nutzergruppe ist, die sehr viel junger ist, als dann die 80-jährige Oma, die uns auch mal eine Mail geschrieben hat. Also irgendwo sehr viel kam tatsächlich früher aus der Hörschaft von Tim, der uns am Anfang sehr viel empfohlen hat. Also ich glaube, wir haben auch eine ganze Menge Männer mit dabei. Aber mittlerweile ist es echt komplett bunt.
Jetzt habe ich noch eine Frage. Habt ihr was zu Doxing gemacht auch?
Noch nicht.
Aber ihr plant es?
Vielleicht. Vielleicht, okay.
Ich halte gerade so die These an. Ihr habt wahrscheinlich zu Doxing gesprochen. Ihr habt auf jeden Fall erzählt, Breitband haben auch was dazu gemacht, dass es anscheinend Themen gibt, die sich überall durchziehen.
Es ist halt so, wir planen tatsächlich immer sehr weit im Voraus. Wir sind auch nicht so aktuell. Wir haben immer mal wieder so aktuelle Gesprächssendungen zwischendrin. Aber meistens sind auch da schon zwei Monate vorher die Themen so aufgelaufen, dass wir dann okay das irgendwie abhaken. Vielleicht reden wir in drei Monaten über Doxing.
Jetzt habe ich euch eingeladen, einerseits um Tatsächlich so Höranregungen auch zu geben, andererseits aber auch natürlich, um jetzt noch mal über das Chaosradio zu sprechen. Weil wir, wie gesagt, das ist heute das letzte auf Fritz. Die Frage ist aber, wie geht das weiter? Und dann könnt ihr vielleicht als Experten für Fachkommunikation noch mal ein bisschen weiterhelfen. Die eine Frage ist, wir haben jetzt hier drei Formate, die funktionieren mit einer relativ kleinen, festen Mannschaft. Also ich glaube, ihr habt alle auch ab und zu Gäste, aber es gibt ein Kernteam, das hört man immer wieder. Also bei euch wechselt sich das, glaube ich, ihr seid drei Leute und zwei davon senden immer mindestens. Genau, aber es ist auch da ein festes Team. Ihr seid jeweils zu zweit, bloß vielleicht noch ein bisschen. Nur Breitband ist eine der Sendungen, also da gibt es mehrere Moderatoren, jedes Mal verschiedene Gäste. Ist das, wenn man das als Audio will, wenn man nicht dachte, wir müssen es sowieso ganz anders machen und machen jetzt irgendwie Instagram-Videos über Fake News, sondern man will über Audio kommunizieren, ist das der Weg, den das gehen muss? Es gibt eine feste Crew, die semiaktuell Dinge diskutiert?
Also ich glaube, ganz zentral für das Format des Podcasts ist schon die Identifikation mit den Menschen, die das machen. Tim nickt schon, also das ist jedenfalls so die Erfahrung, die Philipp und ich gemacht haben bei der Lage. Wir gehen ja auch manchmal raus quasi ins Land, machen so Live-Veranstaltungen und kommen da mit Hörerinnen und Hörern ins Gespräch, die Lage live eben. Und da merkt man das auch ganz deutlich, dass sich da schon so eine Art Beziehung entwickelt zwischen den Hörerinnen und Hörern und den Leuten, die den Podcast machen. Und ich selber kenne das auch aus der Hörerperspektive. Also ich bin zum Beispiel begeisterter Hörer eines bestimmten, etwas nerdigen Podcasts über Entwicklung von iPhone-Apps. Und diesen Podcast betreiben zwei Amerikaner. Und ich habe dann einen von den beiden mal auf einer Entwicklerkonferenz getroffen, auf irgendeinem Flur. Und ich hatte dann so diesen spontanen Impuls, ja, den muss ich jetzt ansprechen, die Handschütteln vielleicht sogar in den Arm nehmen, weil ich so dieses Gefühl von Vertrautheit hatte unmittelbar. Ich dachte, ja, Daniel, Mensch, du bist es doch. Und natürlich kannte der mich überhaupt nicht. Da ist mir aufgefallen, das ist natürlich sehr asymmetrisch, aber es ist zugleich eben doch eine sehr enge Verbindung.
Aber ich frage jetzt ganz konkret fürs Chaosradio. Also heißt das, da sollte es mehr als eine Moderatorin geben, also eher ein Team? Weil das Chaosradio ist ja eigentlich der Club. Also die Idee ist ja eigentlich gar nicht, dass es da eine feste Crew gibt. Aber wäre das vielleicht besser? Kann man das vielleicht neu denken?
Ich würde sagen, dass der Club das Potenzial hat, viel, viel größer sich darzustellen dadurch, also auch diverser. Ich meine, der Club sind seit ihr, die schon ganz lange dabei sind, aber es sind auch ganz, ganz viele jungen Leute, die auf dem 35C3 waren, so viele Leute zum ersten Mal da. Die muss man auch erreichen und die könnten sich auch darstellen. Ich könnte mir die Idee mit so einem jungen Chaosradio oder so was eine Art, ich finde das eigentlich eine ziemlich gute Idee, wenn man da auch anders formatisch denkt, wenn man vielleicht mal auch, keine Ahnung, es ist so einfach möglich, dann geht man einfach mal in die ganzen verschiedenen Hackerclubs, in den verschiedenen Städten und macht mit denen da eine Sendung und stell dich mal vor, man muss nicht immer nur in diesem Studio sitzen und aufnehmen und darüber reden und dann kommen halt die bekannten Gesichter, die natürlich kluge Sachen sagen, sondern in diesen kleinen Ideen, ich glaube, da kann man schon auch mehr rausholen und der Club ist so groß geworden und auch so, wie gesagt, mächtig, einflussmächtig.
Ich glaube aber tatsächlich, wenn es jetzt so eine Art Podcast werden sollte, wo die Leute dann freiwillig immer wieder reinhören, man macht ja einen Podcast mit einer bestimmten Erwartungshaltung an und dazu gehört auch das Gefühl, das sich einstellt, wenn ich diesen Podcast anwache. Es fällt mir sehr schwer, mir was vorzustellen, dass ich regelmäßig anschalte, wo ich nicht weiß, wer redet denn jetzt und wo ich mich wieder neu drauf einstellen muss. Also ich würde das schon eher so konzipieren, dass man jemanden hat, der eine gute Stimme auch hat, eine warme Stimme, eine freundliche Stimme, die man gerne hört und der oder die dann irgendwo hingeht und dann diese verschiedensten Aspekte von Nerdtum und was passiert da gerade und was haben die schon wieder gehackt und dann irgendwelche Basics wieder, also die sozusagen die Leute so reinholt und zeigt und macht, aber eben nicht jedes Mal jemand anderes. Ich glaube, das führt im Zweifel dazu, dass es...
Ja, aber meinst du sagen einen Moderatorin oder Moderator oder noch? Ein letztes Mal müssen wir uns noch an die Uhr halten. Deswegen jetzt, ja, nächste Sendung dann.
Darf ich da mal noch ganz kurz...
Genau, du hast gleich ganz kurz, weil ich möchte euch allen ganz kurz noch euren Wunsch an ein zukünftiges Chaosradio und darf es gerne anfangen.
Okay, aber da waren wir ja im Prinzip und ich finde, dass alles, was ihr gesagt habt, eigentlich stimmt. Also auf der einen Seite, klar, das muss sich jetzt auf jeden Fall mal verjüngen. Kann ja nicht sein, dass die Old Farts hier ewig so weitermachen. Zweitens, ja, neue Sachen. Chaosradio war auch für uns im Club immer auch ein Community-Projekt. Das waren wir uns vielleicht am Anfang nicht so bewusst, aber das ist auf jeden Fall gewesen. Das heißt, wir haben im Prinzip die ganze Bandbreite gezeigt, dadurch, dass immer wieder auch andere Leute waren, immer wieder andere Themen und es immer wieder so war. Ja, das Thema, mega komplex, ist gerade in den Nachrichten. Guck mal, zufällig haben wir da einen Experten am Start. Trotzdem ist es wichtig, dass ein Podcast auch immer von ein, zwei, drei Leuten vielleicht getragen wird, die mehr oder weniger regelmäßig so gefühlt immer dabei sind. Dann kann sich das immer wieder an den Rändern austauschen und ergänzen und so wird dann auch ein richtiges Projekt, ein richtiger Podcast draus.
Also ich würde mir vor allem wünschen, dass das Chaosradio weiterlebt. In dieser Form vielleicht, wie wir es gerade so überlegt haben, da waren ja ganz viele spannende Ideen dabei. Denn ich glaube, dass es wahnsinnig wichtig ist, dass diese Schnittstelle erhalten bleibt zwischen dem Club und den Menschen da draußen, die so gelegentlich mal was zu tun haben mit IT. Und deswegen glaube ich, wäre es auch ganz wichtig, dass eben nicht zu so einer Art Hausmitteilung des TCC zu machen, sondern wirklich diesen in Anführungsstrichen missionarischen Eifer sich zu bewahren, Nerdtum und komplexe IT-Zusammenhänge zu erklären für alle Leute da draußen.
Ich halte mich kurz, denn ich glaube, ich würde sagen, das Einzige, was mir vom zukünftigen Chaosradio wünsche, ist, dass die Pause nur kurz ist, aber dafür kreativ.
Ich schließe mich Johnny Häusler an, der vorhin was gesagt hat in Richtung ältere Leute, die jetzt gerade anfangen mit WhatsApp in diese Welt rein zu gucken. Ich hatte da so ein Erlebnis an Weihnachten, wie vielleicht viele das auch kennen, wenn sie zurückfahren zu ihren Eltern. Die nämlich irgendwie gesagt haben, oh guck mal, auf einmal, wenn ich im Netz irgendwas suche, ist Werbung von etwas, was ich gestern gesucht habe oder sie merken auf einmal dieses Datenschutzding. Sie sind immer komplett überfordert und ich hätte gerne einfach so ein Podcast, hier gucke die Folge Chaosradio, da wird es erklärt und da wird dir auch erklärt, was du tun kannst, um das zu vermeiden.
Okay, ein Chaosradio mit mehreren Leuten in Konstanz, nicht verschwindend und für alle Generationen. Das nehmen wir mal mit in die kreative Pause. Das war das letzte Chaosradio, das Chaosradio Nr. 253 auf Fritz. Wir haben eine kleine kreative Pause, machen wir. Wir melden uns aber auf jeden Fall zurück. Chaosradio.de ist die Webseite, wo ihr all das verfolgen könnt. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe zum Schluss noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer eure Backups.
Tschüss!
Ich habe mehr klickt als Douglas Engelbart.
Ich bin so bossig wie Bowser. Ich erinnere mich nicht mehr an all meine E-Mail-Adressen.
Ich brauche die Internet, wie Whitney Houston braucht den Kran.